hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
meinem kanal heute geht es um das thema
saatgut aufbewahrung und sagt und
organisationen ich zeige euch wie ich
mein saatgut auf bewahre und wie ich das
so organisieren dass ich die samen wenn
ich die dann brauche wenn ich irgendwas
aus sehen wir in meinem garten schnell
und einfach wieder finde viel spaß in
dieser kiste hier beweist mein gesamtes
gemüse saatgut auf diese konstellation
benutze ich so schon seit ungefähr
sieben jahren und entsprechend sieht das
auch aus die gäste hier die welt schon
halb auseinander das ist alles total
glatt wie ich das ganze organisiert
haben jetzt zeige ich euch gleich
nochmal aber ich verpasse in meinem
saatgut jetzt erstmal eine nutzung der
könig eine neue kiste die hier die hat
auch einen deckel sagt sollte man immer
dunkel lagern das konnte ich bei der
liste hier nicht die hat keinen deckel
deswegen ist das edelste zeit dass ich
das mal bescheiden machen und in dem so
kann ich euch dann auch gleich zeigen
wie ich mein saatgut organisieren so was
für in ordnung hier herrscht damit ich
einzelne sagen ganz schnell wieder
wenden
ich sortiere mein gesamtes gemüse sagt
gut nach pflanzenfamilien hier haben wir
zb erstmal wie kohl gewechselt dann
kommen die leguminosen dann kommen die
nachtschattengewächse danach kommen die
doldenblütler ich weiß das nicht jeder
so verrückt ist und alle
pflanzenfamilien auswendig kennt
schreibt mir das mal in die kommentare
ob ihr die pflanzenfamilie auswendig
ganz würde mich echt interessieren oder
ob ich die einzige verrückte bin die die
man auswendig gelernt hat für mich ist
das sehr einfach weil ich sehr sehr
viele unterschiedliche gemüsearten anbau
und natürlich könnte man das auch nach
salat tomaten möhren und so weiter
sortieren aber bei so vielen
verschiedenen gemüsen die wir in unserem
garten anbauen und von dem wir seit gut
lagern würde es sehr lange dauern bis
ich dann genau die röhre unter all den
gemüsen herausgefunden habe dass
mache ich das mit den pflanzen familien
wenn du weniger unterschiedliche
gemüseanbaus dann kannst du das
natürlich auch anders sortieren für mich
funktioniert das so einfach sehr sehr
gut aber eben nicht mehr in den karton
also weil ich mir neue hübschere
unterteilung gebastelt und da sind ihr
euch jetzt die gemüse eingabe ich einmal
die kategorie sonstige weil ich schon
immer mal super abgefahrene
pflanzenfamilien habe für die ich
verdiene ich nur eine pflanze anbau zum
beispiel den feldsalat der ist ein
baldrian gewächs der braucht jetzt nicht
den eigenen reiter der kommt dann in die
sonstigen und danach werde ich jetzt
alle gemüse hier in die neue kiste
einsortieren so dass ich wieder ganz
schön ordentlich habe für die neue
gartensaison
[Musik]
die tatsächlich einen bananen sato
tütchen in meinen kreuz reglern gefunden
was machst du müller übrigens hat schon
mal jemand von euch flowers platz
angebaut
es ist so neue kreuzungen aus rosenkohl
und grünkohl ich will dass dieses ja mal
ausprobieren ich habe die letzten biss
in dem restaurant gegessen und fand die
ziemlich lecker also wenn damit schon
mal jemand erfahrungen hatte schreibt
mir gerne meinen kommentar noch ein
spannendes experiment dieses jahr sind
erdnüsse die habe ich schon gesehen und
bei der gelegenheit merke ich auch
gerade dass ich noch gar keine
leguminosen unterteilung für mein neues
katholischen habe die müssen wir gleich
noch basteln könnt ihr diese teile hier
die immer in schuhkartons drin sind das
sind so kleine jobs illi zu googeln die
feuchtigkeit aufnehmen wie packe ich
immer mit zu meinem saatgut saatgut
sollte man nämlich immer dunkel trocken
und eher kühl lagern also nicht an die
heizung stellen
deckel drauf es jetzt schon passiert und
dann packe ich die dinger rein damit die
die feuchtigkeit aufnehmen und diese
haben möglichst trocken bleiben
die leber minuten hatten noch keine
unterteilung deswegen zeige ich euch
kurz wie ich die gebastelt habe diese
unterteilung einfach ein stück pappe
ausgeschnitten dass in den karton
reinpasst als unterteilung dann habe ich
da tonpapier so gemustertes draufgeklebt
da schreibe ich dann oben in die ecke
noch leguminosen drauf und schon fertig
ist meine sachen die kiste der grip hast
gerade so noch obendrauf und viel mehr
sagt mut dich nicht besitzen helfen wenn
ich mich wahrscheinlich nächstes jahr
nochmal nach einer
die gäste umsehen müssen aber für die
sozial ausreichend und es ist wieder
alles ganz schön ordentlich sortiert mit
dem pflanzenfamilien schildern
dann hat er mir mal unten in den
kommentaren wie ihr euer saatgut lager
drüben gibt es ein video zu meinen fünf
allerliebsten tomatensorten also wenn du
dich fragst welche tomaten anbauen
solltest schau mal da drüben vorbei da
unten ist auch noch ein spannendes video
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja da wieder
biss dann schaut